we're hoping we can imagine two
filmmakers one is an artist and she
spends five years or so focusing only on
the craft of filmmaking and nothing else
she learns story camera angles lenses
blocking and so on so then we have the
other filmmaker and this filmmaker
spends the same five years but only on
the business and she studies the market
financing distribution budgets
networking Etc
which of these two filmmakers do you
think will have a longer lasting career
I would say that the person spending if
if our if two of these two people are on
are one in the same right
um
like it's it's it's Pete and Bizarro
Pete right
and you've got
um I think the the version of this
person that is focused on understanding
The Craft
and is made and I'm gonna add an element
of of a constant of they're both making
thanks
um I would say that the person studying
the craft is going to
um
have a longer career
because they are likely at some point to
make something impactful
they'll they'll be able to take what's
in their heart and put it
on videotape you know I'm going to say
on film but on tape or in a final
product that best represents what they
felt when they started the project
because that's really the Divide right
The Divide is I have this feeling I want
to make this thing
and for a while
the execution doesn't match the
authenticity of the feeling
and then you get to a point where you've
built up enough skills to get pretty
close to how you felt
in how you deliver it for the audience
to feel that way too
the person who is making things
but maybe leaning more into the studying
of the business and and all of that you
know I feel like
the real
asset in the industry is in voice you
know and and is in perspective and so I
feel like
they may know what they may learn what
they're supposed to do or you know
here's
um here's how you do it or you know
but I think
if it's in Broad strokes and in not like
spending the additional time that the
other person is and really mastering the
Craft
um I think I think this person wins okay
what if this person becomes so you know
that their voice is so unique and they
just make this incredible film but
they're naive to the business
is that is that something that could
take them out in some sense I mean it
could take them out I mean you know in
the perfect world they meet a they meet
a really honest agent and manager and
lawyer who is really interested in
nurturing their talent and you know
cares about their
you know or tailors their representation
to the individual you know but
the likelihood of having to rely on that
I think is is uh a gamble I wouldn't
take
you know so like
you know and all not it seems it seems
like the right thing to do but that's
kind of I feel like my book is actually
for the person you're talking about
you know like my book is for the person
who is spending all their time trying to
be creative make XYZ work know how to
pick the right lens and tell the story
in the right way you know but I'm kind
of in their ear saying that's not enough
though
don't forget about this you know have
you read the trades you know and I think
it's the the superhero of this is like
you know is the is the marriage of of
the two people that you're presenting
you know how can you take
uh you know and that's not 50 50.
sometimes it's it's 70 30 because it or
you know it's 70 Business 30 creative
because now I'm in development and I got
to talk to people and I've got to like
have meetings and meetings and then now
I'm making this thing and it's 80 20.
you know now I'm I'm the creative
director and I've got other people
around me taking care of the you know
people management and business of it and
I need to be in that space like
it's a I guess the the real
the real revelation of your question is
the fact that you know you have to kind
of be all these things in my mind if you
want to have the best opportunity at
preserving your intent
um and it's no different you know than
even like in indie films now they talk
about this producer of marketing and
distribution like who's working on you
know social media things well before
you've even gotten the money you know
because it's going to be a value add
down the line
um and I remember I talked to one person
on a dock I was working on he said that
you know people complain about the
middleman or the middle person right and
you know oh I there are these
Gatekeepers and you know we can't do
this we can't do that but the reality of
it is is with the democratization of all
things now
You could argue that the middle person
the gatekeeper is you
and you have to change your
connection to what you're willing to do
because theoretically you could take
your iPhone and shoot it you could take
your computer and get some software and
edit it you could release it on your
website that you designed you could
Market it through your social media
campaigns which you manage like there's
no one stopping you anymore and so
there's no other there's no better time
than now to marry those two profiles
together and I think if you look at the
filmmakers and the storytellers who are
really doing well in today's world
that's exactly what they've done
in your book do you talk about do you
have a chapter about sort of people that
don't want to focus on the business
um I don't have no I don't have a
chapter dedicated to that but I I do
speak specifically to
representation securing it and what you
should look for in that team because
to your point you know at the end of the
day or not at the start of the day too
um your reps get paid when you work
so they work for you they don't actually
send you a check from anywhere connected
to you know their job they're sending
you the check from the people who paid
you to do the show that you did and so
um
really being con thoughtful it's a
partnership it's a marriage like you
have to you have to marry the right
people you know and you have to know
you have to be clear about what you want
um you have to be
you know I think it works best when
you're aware of how the business works
because then they recognize that you are
also you know perhaps more of a partner
than some of their other clients in your
own career and you know at the end of
the day like you you've got to take the
reins on on the business of you